welcome to this video playing nose and
os no wow very very busy account and old
account 1999 that's 16 years old account
cool yeah I also started and i think in
1998 a nice to see but if may I had so
many handled so it's um I always changed
them wanted some variety but the sky is
playing with the same account for for
for more than a decade interesting okie
dokie is so he's playing in a somewhat
restrained fashion here I'm glad to take
all this space I already preferred like
you have to admit what is he going to do
now to see hmm hmm yeah maybe wow just
wow okay I'm taking I'm taking all that
space if you if you are so generous I'm
taking it if at TKE see form takes d1
play Bishop f5 isn't this awkward yeah
it is in some way but it's not not clear
that into them the dead much better
there
I can maybe take and play Bishop f5 this
is a different way to do that using this
kind of this awkward piece placement
yeah 94 as possible maybe yeah let's
let's go for that it's interesting so
yeah he just accepts a somewhat worse
position with the c-4 move but ok it's
not so terribly bad
I'm a piece is a little bit more actor
this is why i'm saying i'm probably
slightly better but as i said it's
nothing it's nothing a super scary if
I'm so I can do this I mean take on b3
this is kind of kind of not very
specific let's do that 94 queen bee six
doesn't let much
my original idea was Lucas look a six
pts Queen B 5 which is a bit awkward
hmm
that's not ideal not really a problem
but definitely not what I wanted I came
yeah maybe just do that yeah probably
here Knight takes b6 is something that
you can maybe play I have Bishop Bishop
c4 as a as a simple reply I don't know
should I do that or do something more
sophisticated like rook e8 Bishop evade
ok let's let's speed up
this is not an attacking move I try what
okay glad to win the pawn wanted to get
some activity for the bishop possibly
but this is a good disturbance pawn
their age pawn let's check them see how
to play still here maybe preparing a
possible Quincy three or something very
difficult to win this kind of position
his active anti always has them has the
opposite colored bishops as a possible
drawing IDM this pressure on f7 is quite
awkward
I have no I have no winning of any
prospects him spite the fact that he
that he had blundered the pawn
ok
time warning yeah IM ok
Bishop f4 I guess it's not really i
cannot play for win this is just like
takes on f7 snow is no winning chance
grin uh yeah yeah not with 30 seconds
but probably okay Bishop f4 wins am I
was thinking I don't I didn't see how
didn't see that I didn't see mate here
that was my problem check I didn't see
how I'm meeting him check I'm not
meeting i'm getting the getting the roof
back and that was winning ah what a
howler well the thing is it was kind of
strange how he played because right here
he just has a draw he just has to stay
put it's a draw but he somehow weakened
himself and played this f 3 and so on
yeah Queen to d5 is just a bad idea now
I have have at least some hope but still
if he just keeps the position like here
and here it's just a draw I mean white
cannot play for win ear that's totally
not realistic I don't know maybe he was
just trying around but okay I didn't I
saw the move of course but I did not see
that I didn't see that here check
whatever he does I'm is getting this
back here I didn't see that one it was a
very very tricky move
yeah the second thing that I think is
interesting I saw that after winning or
after taking c4 it's not not that great
I mean it's of equal equal position I
was thinking I could maybe play this
intending Bishop f8 possibly Bishop here
ok computer gives this as equal probably
because why doesn't really have an
alternative there to a form and then I
can still take yeah but I cannot really
play something like that and allow the
airport to march forward probably not ok
that's not terrible for black but it's
probably not a not a winning idea let's
aim and taking on c4 was simple and good
I wonder if I could have could have
exploited or this a little bit better
because it frankly speaking looks kind
of awkward nitro a one what a move yeah
many ideas but i don't know yeah this
looks it looks a tractor but if always
kind of yeah sorry stodgy but probably
holding look e74 group d 7 that's a good
move by the engine very good 14 actually
yeah yeah I'm better this is a better
better try than 94 probably we get the
same structure now but I have better
better place pieces and it's difficult
for him to to get this sorted out I mean
I even have this kind of interesting
yeah that would have been better than
what I did I think okay well thanks for
watching